wie er wirklich tickt will wohl jeder
gerne wissen aber die us-regierung will
nicht sagen ob sie den mann im kreml
doch für zurechnungsfähig hält ich weiß
nicht wie der präsident putins geistes
schärfe bruchteil
und dem außenministerium es ist nicht
nützlich produktiv oder gar möglich in
präsident putins kopf zu schaffen
doch auch wenn das pentagon bis heute
keine hinweise darauf hat dass putin
wirklich den einsatz von atomwaffen
vorbereitet haben manche ihr urteil
schon gefällt ein ehemaliger
geheimdienstchef zweifel dann putins
geisteswelt ein ex sicherheitsberater
mutmaßt überstimmen in putins kopf
die isolation so ein ex
verteidigungsminister könnte ihn
verwirrt aber kate mccann moran
hirnschall das glauben sie aus den
bildern raus zu lesen aber vielleicht
sollen gerade sie die welt verwirren
rätseln lassen wie es putin wirklich
geht joe biden hat verlässlichere
informationen quellen den putins umfeld
berichten von häufigen wutausbrüchen
geheimdienst cia gibt es eine eigene
abteilung in der wissenschaftler
psychologische profile von anführern
erstellen darunter 1 von putin basierend
auf jahrzehntelanger beobachtung in
diesem buch eigentlich über donald trump
stehen die wichtigsten erkenntnisse
verfasst vom gründer und langjährigen
chef der cia profiling abteilung der
psychologe jarrett post verstarb zwar
2020 aber seine analyse ist für die us
regierung heute noch gültig putin sei
ein narzisst ein brutaler
rücksichtsloser diktator der penibel
pseudo legale rechtfertigungen für seine
taten fabriziert mit übertriebener
gegenwehr kompensiert der seine
unterschwellige unsicherheit putin hat
ein tief sitzendes bedürfnis nicht zu
kapitulieren gegenüber allen versuchen
ihn unter kontrolle zu bringen
putin wird nur abgeschreckt von seinem
vormarsch wenn er auf eine starke und
stählerne antwort von einem geeinten
westen trifft
nach putins gespräch mit dem
französischen präsidenten meldeten mal
als berater dass der kreml chef in dem
stundenlangen termin anders wirkte als
früher
das salz nicht psychologisch stelle ich
sicher keine diagnose ob er sein
verstand verliert aber er agiert an dass
viele leute fragen sich warum die
nachrichtendienste haben nun die harte
aufgabe in seinem kopf zu schauen welche
trading-ideen site ist bilder wie diese
so hall zeigten die isolierung des
russischen präsidenten der in seinem
umfeld auch keinen widerspruch mehr
durch
wenn man sich die gesichter dieser
generäle am tisch ende anschaut als er
über die mögliche bereitschaft redet als
würden sie mal was redet mimik und
gestik sind faszinierend und liefern
hoffentlich gute informationen für die
die solche dinge analysieren
die cia hat putins profil sicher
aktualisiert aber ihr fazit ist
natürlich streng geheim
streng geheim und dann natürlich auch
fraglich wie belastbar ein solches fazit
sein kann denn wie gehört niemand kann
in putins kopf hineinschauen man kann
bestenfalls versuchen aus einem früheren
verhalten rückschlüsse auf die gegenwart
zu ziehen rüdiger von fritsch mal in
seiner zeit als botschafter in moskau
von 2014 bis 2019 häufig in kreml und
hat wladimir putin dort bei gesprächen
erlebt guten tag herr von fritsch zum
trucker passen ihre zeit in moskau liegt
noch nicht lange zurück es war die zeit
um und nach der annexion der krippen
haben sie in diesem zeitraum in diesen
gut fünf jahren eine veränderung im
verhalten putins festgestellt
das ist sicherlich eine entwicklung über
eine lange strecke die wir beobachten
können die sich in den zurückliegenden
jahren nochmals sehr verstärkt hat das
mag beispielsweise auch damit zu tun
haben dass er die vergangenen jahre
nochmal hin zusätzlich in weitgehender
isolation verbracht hat wir wissen wie
streng c't die auflagen waren für
jemanden der in corona zeiten zu ihm
kommen wollte wir sehen die klassischen
entwicklung einer autoritären führung in
der sich jemand völlig verabschiedet von
einer zuverlässigen wahrnehmung der
wirklichkeit und ich fürchte auch von co
im rat wenn du gesehen haben wir im
vergangenen dienstag mit seinem
nationalen sicherheitsrat zusammen
getreten ist dann war das eben nicht ein
kommunistisches politbüro aus
vergangenen zeiten das hinter
verschlossenen türen dem
generalsekretär der kpd es auch immer
wieder sprach das war eine versammlung
vielmehr von claqueuren von schulbuben
der ermahnte quasi am ohr zog vorführte
und das weist darauf hin dass es eben
mit den entscheidungen eines mannes zu
tun haben der mehr und mehr getrieben
ist von obsessionen phobien traumata
behauptet oder tatsächlich empfunden mit
denen er uns zwingt uns zu beschäftigen
und das macht diese ganze situation so
besonders problematisch und wir sehen ja
auch dass sehr vieles tut was zum
schaden seines eigenen landes und auch
seiner interessen ist nicht denn die
massive wirtschaftliche schädigung und
finanzielle schädigung ist eine
schädigung seines landes aber auch
seiner möglichkeit sich dauerhaft die
zustimmung der bevölkerung zu erkaufen
überdies hat er den westen in seltener
einigkeit zusammengeführt und all dieses
zeigt uns dass er nicht mehr in den
interessen seines landes handelt
wirklich und dass er auch keine
wirklichen geopolitischen ziele verfolgt
sondern in groß russischen imperialen
reflexen denkt und handelt er verfügt
wir haben die ferndiagnosen aus den usa
gehört er seiner system wolle und
kontrollierbar bleiben das erscheint ja
nachvollziehbar aber gerade nach den
ereignissen der letzten woche auch der
vergangenen nacht fragt man sich ja
nimmt am ende sogar eine nukleare
eskalation in kauf
ich habe zwei hoffnungen zum einen dass
der russische präsident unverändert weiß
was im artikel 5 des nato vertrags steht
dass ein angriff auf einen
mitgliedstaaten angriff auf das bündnis
bedeutet und meine zweite hoffnung dass
sollte er glauben weiter eskalieren zu
müssen sich in moskau doch noch jemand
findet der ihm in den arm fällt und das
ist aus den kreisen der führungen auch
nicht auszuschließen ja sie haben die
generäle eben schon angesprochen auch
die geheimdienstmitarbeiter die man
dabei den gesprächen in den letzten
tagen und wochen gesehen hat sind die
ihm alle bis in den tod ergeben fragt
man sich oder bekommen sie sich eben
tatsächlich vorstellen dass irgendwann
ein punkt erreicht ist
wo sie ihm dann doch einhalt gebieten
das ist nur ein stück weit realität aus
überzeugung und daneben herrschte der
russische präsident wie in der
bevölkerung auch in seiner führung mit
den klassischen mitteln der angst der
repression der abhängigkeit der
bestechung das kommt alles zusammen und
hier sind verstrickungen entstanden aus
denen sich diese person nicht ohne
weiteres lösen können aber noch einmal
ich würde nicht ausschließen wollen dass
wenn es zu einer zuspitzung kommen soll
die weiter russlands interessen massiv
schadet dass es jedoch einen auch sehr
tatkräftigen widerspruch geben könnte
das eine hoffnung andere setzen auch
eine hoffnung auf widerstand gegen putin
in die russische bevölkerung vor allem
dann wenn immer sichtbarer wird wie
verlustreich der krieg krieg eben auch
für russland wird ist diese hoffnung
berechtigt aus ihrer sicht oder
überschätzt dass die möglichkeiten der
einfachen menschen in russland
was wir gegenwärtig an protest in
russland sehen ist zum einen ungeheuer
mutig ich bewundere diese menschen
grenzenlos sie wissen welche ungeheuren
risiken sie eingehen ab heute gelten
bestimmung nach denen solche proteste
und widerstand gegen das die offizielle
erzählung des status mit bis zu 15
jahren straflager bestraft werden können
das sind der menschen die aus
überzeugung an die große menge der
menschen duckt sich er weg und ich meine
das nicht abfällig ich habe verständnis
für diese menschen die die signale der
angst die ausgesandt werden sehr gut
lesen können die sich erinnern an die
repression vergangener zeiten an die
furchtbaren schicksale ihrer
vorfahren und jetzt gilt in russland die
alte frage sieg der fernseher oder sieht
der kühlschrank nicht bisher sieg der
fernseher ist halt die staatliche
propaganda hängt so sehr dass die
menschen das zum teil glauben wollen und
dass sie überdies sagen besser sich
nicht aufmucken das könnte gefährlich
werden aber sollte der kühlschrank
siegen das heißt sollte die soziale und
wirtschaftliche lage der menschen schwer
werden weil dem präsidenten eben auch
die einnahmen fehlen um die bevölkerung
ständig bei laune zu halten sich ihre
zustimmung zu erkaufen dann ist nicht
auszuschließen dass an einem bestimmten
punkt es plötzlich doch zu größerem
unmut kommt und das ist ganz
offensichtlich etwas was der russische
präsident selber sehr fürchtet sonst
würde er in solchen
in seinem land nicht mit solcher
repression arbeiten das aber dann wohl
eher eine mittel- oder langfristige
perspektive rüdiger fritsch von 2014 bis
2019 botschafter in moskau vielen dank
für ihre einschätzung